what a reveal you you become data again
right everybody thought it was a goodbye
yeah that was it well I've died twice
you know uh and and very likely will
again at some point not in episode I
mean were you surprised did you know all
along oh well I knew I I mean the Terry
metallis who uh and show her in the the
and directed the last two episodes uh
you know we we talked about it before we
started can we do this can I get away
with this how do I do this because data
is different when you see them again
it's a different data wow yeah was it
cool to play yeah it was it was it was
like really can I pull this off because
he is different he's uh you know there
was a thing Roddenberry I'll say this
really really briefly but from the very
beginning Rod Mary said uh here's what I
want from data I want him to get as The
Show Goes On get closer and closer and
closer to being human and by the end
still not